today on the matt walsh show president
biden goes into hiding as his afghan
withdrawal plan falls apart i have quite
a lot to say about this subject and by
the end if i've done my job i will
probably have ticked off everyone on all
sides of the issue which is always fun
also the american academy pediatrics
gaslights the critics of masking
children while the surgeon general
declares that you do not have the right
don't have the right to share opinions
that he deems misinformation plus tim
tebow made his nfl debut of the weekend
which is proof of racism according to
many people in the sports media and our
daily cancellation i'll respond to my
critics who say that i am a white
supremacist conspiracy theorist because
of something that i said on my show on
friday so nothing new there i suppose
all of that and much more today on the
matt walsh
yeah there are a few things when it
comes to your health and well-being
there are a few things more essential
and more basic than getting a good
night's sleep and i say this as someone
who currently right now did not get a
good night's sleep last night uh only
because our four-year-old was having
nightmares and you know waking us up and
it's been going on for a couple nights
now uh but
i cannot blame my pillow for that my
pillow all else as long as no
four-year-olds are interfering uh my
pillow will ensure that you get the best
night's sleep you could possibly imagine
and not just because of their pillow all
their other products as well including
the giza dream bed sheets uh my pillow
has their world's the world's best
uh
sheets called giza it's ultra soft and
breathable but extremely durable my
pillow sheets come with a 60-day
money-back guarantee and a 10-year
warranty the first night you sleep on
the geezer sheets you will never want to
sleep on anything else guaranteed these
dream sheets come in a variety of sizes
and colors my pillow's latest incredible
deal is the sale of the year for a
limited time you'll receive 50 off the
giza dream sheets you'll receive a set
for as low as 49.99 you don't want to
miss this so go to mypillow.com click on
the radio listener square use promo code
dailywire there you'll find not only
this amazing offer but also deep
discounts on all my pillow products you
can call
1-800-651-1148 use promo code dailywire
or go to mypillow.com and make sure you
use the promo code dailywire
if you've listened to this show for any
length of time you know that i prefer to
focus almost 100 of the time on things
happening in this country and to this
country especially those things which
may most immediately impact your family
and your children
those kinds of issues serve as the
nucleus of this show and it's not
because events across the world are
unimportant in the grand scheme it's
just that we can only focus our
attention on a limited number of things
and solve a limited number of problems
and so i choose
those things and problems which are
closest to us
as it happens
our own society is in the grip of
several crises all at once
cataclysms which are only accelerating
the fall and decay of our once great
civilization i don't think we have the
luxury to spend very much time trying to
fix the world's problems
even it would be even if it would be
otherwise wise and noble to try which it
isn't in my view
our attention is urgently needed in our
own communities and households we can't
afford to take the eye off of that ball
we can't wander off into the wilderness
searching for far-off dragons to slay
because because we have more than enough
of them here
though they may take different forms
from what you find elsewhere on earth
all of that is a long way of saying
that the situation in afghanistan
is not the sort of thing i would
normally talk about on this show
as you've heard i'm sure biden moved to
finally withdraw our troops from
afghanistan but apparently had no real
plan for evacuating everybody safely the
taliban moved in took over the country
in about two days while the afghan army
and government fled into the night
like real heroes
now afghanistan is back in the spot it
was in 20 years ago only it's worse
really because the taliban claims
possession of all of the munitions and
artillery that we left behind
um
so
with all of that going on i'm going to
make an exception to my normal rule rule
at least for today
and offer a few comments about all of
this
i'm not an expert
on afghanistan but then again the
experts on afghanistan much like the
public health experts here in the u.s
have largely created the very problems
that they're supposed to be the experts
on solving so it once again falls to
rational people to use common sense to
throw to sort through all of this
and that's what i'll try to do now on
that end
three primary points i think need to be
made
first of all
there's no question that biden's
withdrawal has been handled so poorly
that to use a word like poorly is to
pay biden an undue compliment
the president of the united states who
may or may not be conscious and
cognizant right now who knows is
hunkered down in camp david and refusing
to address the american people or
explain his strategy i mean last night
it was announced that even biden's press
secretary posaki will be m.i.a for the
next week
you know the the people that tried to
send her an email got a got a form
response saying i'll be back in about a
week
hope there's nothing urgent that you
need
the biden regime is literally in hiding
as the u.s installed afghan regime
surrenders the country to the taliban
and americans in the country are left
stranded
so the only real question now is whether
biden knew
that it would go this way and lied
or if he's really so clueless and
mentally degraded at this point that he
believed the nonsense he spewed at a
press conference just a month ago let's
listen to that again this was back
in the in early july here's what he said
about leaving afghanistan and how he
expected it would go let's watch
is the taliban takeover of afghanistan
now inevitable no
it is not
because you have the afghan troops have
300 000
well-equipped as well as equipped as any
army in the world
and an air force against something like
75 000 taliban
it is not inevitable
mr president thank you very much your
own intelligence community has assessed
that the afghan government will likely
collapse that's not true
is it can you please clarify what they
have told you about whether that will
happen or not that is not true
they did not they didn't did not reach
that conclusion so what is the level of
confidence that they have that it will
not collapse the afghan government
and leadership has to come together
they clearly have the capacity
to sustain the government in place
yeah about that
well the afghan government did collapse
and the afghan middle military didn't
even so much as put up a fight
they came together on the road as they
were getting their asses out of there
um i i'm not sure if a single shot was
actually fired in defense of kabul it
was always clear to all intelligent
people that the withdrawal from
afghanistan
would play out this way
biden should have built a plan which
accounts for that but instead he denied
the obvious facts on the ground and
planned for a leisurely peaceful exit
one where i guess the afghan government
and military waves goodbye to our troops
as they leave in shots we'll take care
of things here you all have a safe trip
home now
the taliban look on from their caves
decide that it'll be rude to move in and
undo all of america's hard work over the
past two decades no we're not going to
do that that would be you know that's
not fair that's what biden imagined or
at least wanted us to imagine
i'm willing to believe that he himself
actually did imagine that given that his
brain is operating at 40 capacity at
best
and was never terribly powerful even
with all of its batteries fully charged
but the people actually running the
administration those who are really in
charge of our government and we don't
know exactly who those people are by
design
knew that it would be a bud bloodbath on
the way out and we're apparently okay
with that
for this reason much of the criticism
that biden is sustaining right now is
completely justified and 100 warranted
there are even calls for him to resign
which are also warranted though we
should always keep in mind that you know
what's waiting in the wings will not be
by any stretch of the imagination in
improvement
but second point with all that said
many of the people on the right and on
the left who are complaining about the
exit from afghanistan are upset
apparently
that we are exiting from afghanistan at
all
for these people the issue is not just
the manner of the exit
but the fact of the exit
they believe that even after 20 years
america still owes a debt to afghanistan
and must remain there indefinitely
and there and from what i've noticed by
the way um
there are a lot of people on this side
of the debate
who like
up to a month ago we're claiming to be
non-interventionist
there are many republicans right now and
again we're leaving it yes yes it was it
was handled poorly i got that
moving on from that discussion
there are many so-called or or alleged
non-interventionist conservatives
who have completely dropped that now
just like that
you know trump made it cool to be a
non-interventionist conservative and so
a lot of conservatives especially in the
republican party and prominent ones in
media kind of pretended to be that
and now many of them are fully back on
board with no no let's stay there
forever i mean let's literally stay
there forever
yes and many of the people on this side
of the debate like to point out that
america still has bases in countries
like japan and germany
why can't we maintain a presence in
afghanistan as well
well these people are
are incredibly wrong
for these reasons leaving aside for a
moment the way that the withdrawal was
handled again
it is inarguably true that there needed
to be a withdrawal
yes we maintain bases in japan and
germany you could make a very compelling
argument that we shouldn't have them
there either especially as those
countries are more than capable of
defending themselves but there's also a
significant difference here
japan and germany are countries
actual real nations
afghanistan is not
afghanistan is a medieval third world
hell pit with no will to exist on its
own accord i mean think about it we
armed and equipped the afghan military
for 20 years
biden claims that it was 300 000 strong
that figure's probably false like
everything else biden says but let's use
it for the sake of argument i mean it
was certainly large at any rate it was a
large army
much larger than the taliban forces and
yet the afghan army after 20 years of
training
folded in two days to a gang of
seventh century terrorists who they
outnumbered three to one
the army and the government surrendered
gave up
abandoned ship immediately
without even a symbolic attempt at
fighting back
not so much as firing a shot in most
cases they just left
what does that tell us
it tells us that afghanistan is a
country that we built
but we built it like a deck of cards
it needs our constant presence our
sacrifice and blood and treasure simply
to exist
the whole country is like the highway
system in afghanistan that we spent
billions constructing did you know that
you spent billions on on building
highways in afghanistan you did
and then the afghan government and the
afghan people they let it fall
immediately into disrespect disrepair
it's now crumbled and largely unusable
because the people we built it for
refuse to maintain it
and that's the story of afghanistan it
has always been the story
forcing this
country on people who don't want it
have no interest in it
a point that few people will make but i
will even if it sounds harsh
i want you to look at this footage from
the
kabul airport
here it is here uh people are are
fleeing you've got fleeing afghans
trying to climb onto the evacuation
plane as it speeds down the runway which
by the way is
not a good plan of action
apparently some of them actually you can
see them there they jumped on
you could see them holding to the side
of the plane while it was taking off
and then fell to their deaths as the
plane took off which of course that's
how that was going to work out
now it's a tragic scene shortly but it's
tragic in more than just the obvious way
because what else do you notice about
this crowd
what do you see
or more specifically what do you not see
women
children
these are almost all men
and you can look at any of the footage
of these you know stampeding hordes of
people trying to get out of afghanistan
look at any of the footage and you're
going to see predominantly almost
exclusively men
mostly of fighting age from the looks of
it i mean these aren't elderly men
sprinting down the airport runway
so mostly young men scrambling to leave
just as the army left
can i ask the impolite question
why aren't these men fighting for their
country
we're now going to be guilted now into
accepting thousands of them as refugees
not concerned that there could easily be
taliban hiding in their midst but more
to the point
men of afghanistan do not seem willing
to fight to protect the families of
afghanistan
and yet our men should
our young men should die on afghan
afghanistan soil to do what afghan men
will not do
refuse to do
it bears repeating over and over again
the afghan army
and the afghan men they were not
defeated they just gave up
right away that's it
this is what it comes down to
we cannot hold into existence a country
which does not want to exist
we cannot task ourselves with the
responsibility of sustaining nations
which lack the willpower to sustain
themselves
we especially can't do that while our
own nation struggles in its own way to
exist
and that brings me to the third point
maybe you remember this tweet from the
u.s embassy in kabul
just just two months ago this is what
they were tweeting
says the month of june is recognized as
lgbti pride month the united states
respects the dignity and equality of
lgbti people and celebrates their
contributions to the society
we remain committed to supporting civil
rights of minorities including lgbti
persons
this is what our ruling class has become
this is the kind of empire they seek to
build this is what they want to export
out into the world when they're not at
home chasing down you know other terror
threats like anti-massacres and old
ladies who trespass in the capital
and when they're not on tv preaching
about racial diversity and cultural
sensitivity
i mean one seriously wonders whether our
military left copies of white fragility
and you know i am jazz at the embassy
for the taliban when they took over i
wouldn't be surprised if that was the
plan i would not be surprised
the point is that even if you're a fan
of nation building and colonization and
that's what we did in afghanistan if you
support
what we did in afghanistan and you want
to see more of it you are by definition
a colonizer
but even if you like the idea in theory
the fact is that our government in our
military as it is currently run and
constructed
is not capable of building and
sustaining a global empire
a government waving rainbow flags and a
military indoctrinated into lgbt
and critical race theory propaganda
cannot be an imperial force even if it
wants to be
most of the people defending american
imperialism abroad
seem to want to pretend
that we're still the country we were 100
years ago we're not
and that brings us back to where we
started
uh back at home
in the throes of our own crisis
our own struggle to simply exist
a struggle that calls for all hands on
deck
let the afghans fight for afghanistan
if they will not
it will fall
already has because they didn't
just as if we don't fight for our own
country
so will
it now let's get to our five headlines
and now a quick word from
rock otto i don't know if i ever have
mentioned this before but it's really
hot outside
why you want to go outside and go to the
auto parts store when you could just
stay inside and go on your phone go to
rockauto.com and this is especially true
if you need an auto part that is
necessary to the functioning of your car
that's going to be all the more reason
to order it on rockauto.com
rockguard.com is so much easier and just
better and more efficient and cheaper
than walking into an auto parts store
they always offer the lowest prices
possible and they're a family business
they've been serving auto parts
customers online for 20 years you go to
rockauto.com to shop for auto and body
parts from hundreds of manufacturers
the great thing about the catalog is
that it's unique they've got all kinds
of parts and that you won't find
elsewhere but it's really easy to
navigate and find all the different
parts that you might need quickly see
all the parts available for your vehicle
and choose the brands specifications and
prices that you prefer you can't beat
rockauto.com i dare you to try so go to
rockauto.com right now see all the parts
available for your car truck and write
walsh in there how did you hear about us
box so they know that we sent you
uh before we get back to the arg
arguably more important stuff can i uh
can i just get your opinion on something
real quick
um yet again i am being attacked and
persecuted
for the crime of being a fashion
innovator
so i walked out of our bedroom on friday
night getting ready to go on tucker
carlson's show sorry to name drop but
that's that's the context and anyway
this is what i was wearing you can see
it there i've got the um uh i'm looking
fly as the kids would say dare i say fly
af
whatever that means
i know what it means um i've got the tan
shirt tan pants a little bit of the kim
jong-un aesthetic going on maybe a
little maybe like a park ranger chasing
down yogi bear i don't know um but my
wife said i look like an oompa loompa
and she just starts laughing
hysterically and takes a picture and
posted online to shame me apparently
wearing tan and tan
is the ultimate fashion crime i don't
know um so you tell me who's in the
right here my wife the cyber bully
and this is this is cyber bullying and
it's not a joke
or or me the fashion pioneer
and style icon
just tell me your honest opinion i i'm
confident in my position here that's why
i throw myself at the mercy of the court
because i know i know the truth
that is who's
we had this whole discussion about
matching like what do you mean oh it
doesn't it you're supposed to match your
clothes right well it matches it's like
literally the same color how does that
not count as matching
doesn't make any sense
all right um
there has perhaps
not been
as we move on here
we talked about the experts and how the
experts in every area uh can be
discarded um
can be can be disregarded and discarded
but there's perhaps not been any public
health organization which has become
itself more in the past few years than
the american academy of pediatrics
and i know you might say well
what about the uh the cdc what about
you know
the nih or the or who or you know
literally all of them i mean they've all
done a terrible job and that's true but
so there's a lot of competition for this
title
but the aap the american academy
pediatrics they stand apart i think
because they deal specifically with kids
and they've done so much
harm to kids not just in regards to
covet although that also but also with
endorsing trans affirming health care
and all that kind of stuff over the last
few years
so here's the latest
from the american academy of pediatrics
they tweeted this out a few days ago
talking about masking and it's a whole
long thread i'll read through some of
this
this is a this is like a master class in
gaslighting
if you're wondering what gas gaslighting
looks like this is it
they say school is starting and masks
can be especially important for children
younger than age 12 who are not eligible
for the cove vaccines here's some real
talk about masks as kids are hashtag
back together this fall
research shows that schools where
children or adults are consistently
masked are effective in preventing the
transmission of coven 19. kobe remains a
serious threat to children's health
universal masking can help make
in-person learning safe this fall we
want our children back to school in
person but many students will not yet be
eligible to get cover 19 vaccines masks
are important layer of protection
face masks do not reduce oxygen intake
carbon dioxide molecules are very tiny
even smaller than respiratory droplets
they cannot be trapped by breathable
materials like cloth or disposable masks
and then they say
babies and young children study faces so
you may worry that having masked
caregivers would harm children's
language development
there are no studies to support this
concern
young children will use other clues like
gestures and tone of voice okay so like
i said gaslighting
dictionary definition here that's what's
going on
and then
specifically two areas
first of all they say um
that
uh
that research shows that schools where
children and adults are consistently
masked are effective in preventing the
transmission of covet 19.
you know what they're not telling you
about
what about the schools where they didn't
mask
okay so their claim is that oh well you
know we see we can look at schools where
they masked last year and there wasn't a
lot of coveted spread and so that proves
that the masks work
what about when you compare that to the
schools that didn't wear them
because we know that kids are very
unlikely to contract or spread uh
coven 19 much less to have a severe
reaction to it
so the fact that they're kids
that's already doing a large part of the
work here
they're not going to tell you that
though they're not going to give you
that comparison all they're going to
show you is
here's a school that had masks on look
at that the virus didn't spread they're
not going to show you the other school
over here in a different state that
didn't have masks and also didn't have
much viral spread
and uh and that but that is nothing
compared to
the final claim which is that um well
you may be worried that you're depriving
young children of the ability to see the
faces of their teachers and caregivers
and
that's gonna that's gonna hurt language
development that's a that's a point that
i have made many times i made it in my
school board speech
and have made it before and others have
made it
and they say oh no don't worry about
that there are no studies to support
that concern
yeah i believe that that is true there
are no studies to support that concern
do you know why there are no studies
because prior to right now
nobody would have even
considered studying that
prior to right now nobody would have
thought well let's let's do a study to
see if um children can learn when their
teachers are wearing masks
let's put masks on all the kids and see
if they can still learn to read
that study hasn't been done no one's
done it because no one was crazy enough
to try it until right now
it wasn't an issue that was anywhere on
the radar for anyone
even though there were
as i've said so many times now and we'll
continue saying even though there were
transmissible
missile diseases out there like the flu
which is a greater danger to kids than
covid
nobody ever considered masking
and that's why there are no studies
so anytime you hear well there are no
studies to support this
all that tells you if it's true which
i i wouldn't believe anything these
people say on the surface
i wouldn't take any of it at face value
but pretending that it is true in this
case i believe there are no studies but
that is only because
there was no cause to do a study like
that
and also you know what else it's so
obvious
that of course it will affect language
development
that that's yet another reason why it
was never studied before
now we're going to get the real world
study because we're using our kids our
kids are the study objects now they are
the lab rats that we're studying
they're the guinea pigs
so we're going to see
we're going to see what happens when you
put kids in masks
for
some of these kids this will now be
their second year of being masked you
know take kids in there
at the young age when they're really
starting to read at like five let's see
what happens put put up take but take
thousands of kids at the age of five put
them in masks until they're seven or
eight
and put their teachers in masks too and
see how well they learn to read and
compare that to kids in the past who who
didn't have that hurdle to to get over
i guarantee you we're going to discover
that it causes serious severe
um problems in terms of language
development
guaranteed
because the aap they even acknowledge
that young children use faces and they
say well they can use other cues
well you know that's it's fine they have
other cues
when they have the face to go on they
also have those other cues and so they
have all of these things together you
know learning to read is hard it doesn't
it doesn't come automatically
to kids it's a difficult thing to do
so we want to give them all of the tools
in the toolbox
you're taking one of the most essential
tools out of the equation and saying
yeah they'll figure it out
they might that doesn't mean they're not
going to be harmed in the process
um so we'll get that study yeah
and then but we could know for sure the
american academy of pediatrics they're
never going to come back around and say
hey we really got that one wrong turns
out
turns out yeah when you when you
when you put everyone in masks for years
and then expect kids to learn how to
read and enunciate words when they can't
see the teacher
actually enunciating the words it turns
out that causes real problems well we
got that wrong sorry about that
they will never do that
never
they will never admit they're wrong
if you contradict them or disagree with
them you're spreading misinformation
and then when they change their mind and
start saying the opposite of what they
were saying before
uh
you're still spreading this information
and you don't have the right to do that
as the surgeon general who was on cable
news over the weekend
explained he said he was on cnn and he
said you you simply do not have the
right
to
propagate anything that he considers to
be misinformation let's listen to that
journalists in the media have an
incredibly important role and
responsibility in preventing the spread
of misinformation while we all have the
right to make our own choices we don't
have the right to irresponsibly spread
misinformation and look i believe in my
conversations with uh media outlets that
this doesn't have to be a partisan issue
i've
had many conversations with folks across
the political spectrum in terms of
journalists who absolutely want to do
the right thing in terms of getting
accurate information out to the public
so this doesn't have to be
partisan but what we do need uh
journalists and media organizations to
look deeply at are their current
practices we need them first of all to
make sure
that they are putting forward credible
sources when they do their interviews
and when they push out coverage we need
them to make sure that they are
providing context also not just for
example reporting on a side effect but
making sure people understand that that
side effect might be incredibly rare
uh did you notice
two quick points to make here
i don't know if you noticed
uh when he was talking about credible
sources he says
we we have to make sure
that
the credible sources are being used and
then cnn flashes up on the screen some
headlines examples of of of good good
media outlets that use credible sources
and what's the one thing
that all of those quote unquote credible
sources have in common they're
government sources the cdc and the white
house
here's an example of a credible source
the government that that's that's what
the government is saying a credible
source is us
anything outside of us
is not a credible source
and they're at the point now saying uh
not just
that you're being irresponsible and
you're being a very bad person and all
these other things
if you uh
you know articulate positions that they
disagree with
he is now saying you do not have the
right to do it you don't have the right
to spread misinformation
and that of course is incorrect
you absolutely do
yeah i have the right
i have the constitutional right to
spread what you consider to be
misinformation
and that's the really important part
here what you consider to be if you're
in the government the the surgeon
general
what he considers to be misinformation i
have the right to say that and to spread
it
far and wide
this is uh this is convincing to a lot
of people i think
this is how easily fooled a lot of
people are
the government could say well of course
you have free speech rights you could
you could say whatever you want
but but of course to say things that are
incorrect well that's that's
irresponsible you get people killed
and and how do you know what's correct
and incorrect well we'll tell you
so you have the right to say whatever
you want your free speech we are a free
country god bless america
uh but
but
obviously only if you're saying correct
things
don't worry about trying to figure out
if what you're saying is correct
we'll tell you
we'll give you the approved list of
things that are that are correct that
you can say on any given subject
and you can say those things
and you know what you can say those
things all you want
when it comes to covet here's a list of
five things that you can say
and we're so generous that you you could
say those five things 100 times each a
day if you want to in fact we encourage
it
you have the right to say everything on
that page on that list of five things
but anything outside of that that
doesn't even count as speech that's just
that's really a terrorist attack if
anything
but as always
it doesn't
even disturb me all that much to hear
this kind of nonsense
from bureaucrats and government
officials
because i expect it from them
of course people in government are going
to try to pull
this these sorts of stunts
of course they are
i i know that
they're always going to be looking for
ways to increase their power and
authority and to shut down opposition i
realized that because i understand the
mentality of the sorts of people who get
into this line of work in the first
place
most of the people who are in government
in these positions of authority whether
elected or in the bureaucracy the reason
that they're there is because of their
psychotic sociopathic desire and need to
control people that's why they're there
it's not the case for all of them but
most of them
and it's it's a big inherent problem
there's no real way around it that most
of the people who desire to do these
kinds of jobs it's for
reasons that are less than magnanimous
it doesn't mean they're all they all go
into this to become super villains but
it's just it's self-centered and
self-serving
they believe that they should be in
control of other people they they know
how you should live your life and they
want to be in a position to
[Music]
guide you down that path against your
will if necessary for your own sake
that's what they believe that's why
they're in that position
so i know that
um
[Music]
and if you allow them they'll this is
what they'll do
what disturbs me are all the normal
people who fall for this
who hear a government official say yeah
you have the right to say everything
unless we call it misinformation in
which case you can't say it obviously
because that's a terrorist attack and
that's you're hurting people
what disturbs me are all the people that
hear that and think well it makes sense
yeah
that makes a lot of sense
all right let's go to some nfl news
tim tebow made his in-game debut for the
jags during their pre-season game played
a few snaps not much happened
but then the leftists and sports media
came rushing in with more of this
so here is a dead spin reporter chuck
modi says tim tebow is playing in the
nfl
colin kaepernick eric reid kenny stills
are blackballed from the nfl tell me
again how black lives matter roger
goodell who's the commissioner of the of
the nfl now personally by the way i have
no problem people attacking roger
goodell this is fine with me
roger goodell's done all he can it's the
same story
you know over and over again he's done
all he can to appease the woke mob and
they still hate his guts
so he deserves to be eaten alive by them
as he is but
this is going to be the story you know
what i i root for this is what this is
what's hard for me especially as a
football fan and a tebow fan because i
like tim tebow he's an easy guy to root
for
he's easy to root for because
he's uh he he works hard he's a humble
guy
he just wants to contribute to the team
and it's easy to root for people like
that
so i want to see him succeed i think
it'd be great
i don't think it's likely but if tim
tebow could go out at the age of 33
playing a position he's never played
before and have a decent year you know
catch 40 balls or something and and
score four or five touchdowns that would
be that'd be an amazing story
and it would be a lot of fun
so i hope it happens and it also it'll
piss off the right people which is also
fun
but then we're going to have to hear
stuff like this
incessantly throughout the entire season
every time tim tebow is seen on camera
doing anything
you're gonna get
people in media doing this routine well
this is tim tebow why is it guys and
colin kaepernick out there do you know
why colin kaepernick is not playing
tight end for the jet for the
jacksonville jaguars for a venom veteran
minimum salary which is what tim tebow
is doing
trying out in training camp with no
guarantee that he'll even make the team
do you know why colin kaepernick isn't
doing that because he doesn't want to do
that
he has no interest in doing that
tim tebow this goes back to his humility
and what makes him easy to root for
he's also patriotic and he loves his
country that's another thing that we
like to see from our athletes and we
rarely do these days
but um
he
is trying out in training camp
knowing that he could get cut from the
team
he's going to get paid the minimum
salary which is still a nice salary but
it's not the the you know tens of
millions that other players are getting
and
he's playing a position
he's trying to fit in at any other
position because he knows he's not going
to make the team as a quarterback
because he's not good enough and he's
not
colin kaepernick was never willing to do
that
colin kaepernick even at this point
wants to be a starting quarterback
for an nfl franchise
and get paid starting quarterback money
that's what he wants
he wants to waltz onto the field be
given the starting job
get paid a bunch of money
[Music]
and if you're if you're the the coach of
a team and
he's on your squad and you don't give
him that position you know he's gonna
call he's gonna accuse you of racism and
start protesting on the sidelines
and turn half of your locker room
against you
all while he also is not a good
quarterback he wasn't good when he left
five or six years ago he's not going to
be better now
older and having not played for half a
decade
so just so you know if you don't follow
football and you see this kind of thing
we're going to see a lot of it
that is why that's why kaepernick is not
out there doing what tebow is doing
because he doesn't want to do what
tebow's doing and who can really blame
him
he's making hundreds of millions
just sitting on his butt complaining
he's he's a bigger star now and is far
wealthier than he ever was as a as an
athlete
so why would he want to do this
he would be taking a significant pay cut
if he were to go and
do what tim tebow was doing right now
so it's kind of a double-edged sword
yeah i want to root for tebow but then
it's i'm going to be seriously annoyed
by all the kaepernick stuff
in the end though it's still
on balance i think tebow still we have
to we have to root for him so
uh but i i i don't necessarily like his
chances of making the team just because
he is a 33 year old man playing a
position that he's never played before
but all right let's uh move on now to
reading the youtube comments
um mike says as a registered nurse i'm
sick of the nurses or heroes bs
if as a nurse you need that level of
validation i question your ability
to do the job competently a lot of
comments like this and messages i've
gotten from nurses who are saying the
same thing that they're tired of this
also
of the constant over-the-top praise of
nurses and they're all heroes
and i can see how people who are nurses
would get tired of that because number
one thing it's number one it's annoying
and infantilizing and patronizing
but also if you're a nurse then you work
with other nurses
and you know better than anyone that
it's just like any other job and you
work with plenty of people who are
terrible at their job
and don't deserve this kind of praise
that they're automatically getting
because we're giving it to everybody
um
hot crap
great name says matt's ads are the best
by far i know he hates doing them which
makes it hilarious
sir this claim is itself hot crap i love
all of my advertisers there is nothing i
enjoy more than reading the ads and i
don't know why you would accuse me of
that i take offense to that personally
it's my greatest joy and passion in life
is reading the ads i look forward to it
it's what gets me up in the morning
knowing that i can get in here and tell
you about all of our great sponsors and
then you would accuse me of this
it's not right it is not right
you're banned from the show
needless to say lightweight jive says uh
he's talking about young people with no
ambition he says they don't have the
desire coupled with overbearing
helicopter parents that try to live
their life for them
and would never let them take risks uh
etc
yeah you know the taking risks thing i
think is a big part of this is we talk
about um
this this lack of ambition in a lot of
young people they don't have the desire
to get out there and you know live their
own lives and be independent
um
and yeah big that that's that's
something that parents should do
and specifically fathers
this this is a this is a special role
it's not that mothers can't do it but
this is a thing that fathers are
especially equipped to do in my view
and that is to
help their kids take
safe
and reasonable risks
of different types
because there are different kinds of
risks there are physical risks you know
go climb the tree and yeah you could
fall out and i mean you know you could
even seriously hurt yourself but it's a
it's a reasonable risk especially as the
kid is younger i'm here you know and if
you do fall i'll catch you and we're not
gonna let you you know i'll point you to
the right tree to climb don't climb that
one because the branches are too thin
that kind of thing so there's there's
the physical risks
um
especially as kids get older there's
kind of the intellectual risks
the moral risks
to
go out and defend
your principles to express your point of
view
knowing they might get shouted down
people might laugh at you people are
going to disagree with you
and um again mothers can do that too but
i think that
fathers
are especially useful in this regard
teaching their kids how to take risks
encouraging them to take risks
um
and a lot of kids grow up without any
fathers in the house at all
and uh even
many of the fathers who are physically
present aren't really
present in any other sense of the word
and they're not teaching their kids that
and then what you end up with is either
because it could go either way or it
could be a combination
but you end up either with kids who are
terrified of taking any risks at all
and want to stay in their homes and not
leave
staying on their on their phones and
playing video games doing low-risk
activities
uh conforming themselves entirely with
their peer culture doing and saying
whatever everyone else is doing
so you have a lot of that
and you also have kids who are so
desperate to take risks but have never
been taught how to take risks and so
they go out and and take the wrong kinds
of risks
like the kind of risk that a you know 17
year old teenage boy might take
when he's
driving down the the road at 2 o'clock
in the morning at
95 miles an hour hits a tree and dies
like that kind of risk right
the wrong kind of risk
that's that's what we end up with we end
up with a lot of
a lot of young people who are allergic
to all sorts of risks
then you have others that are that are
taking reckless very unsafe the wrong
kinds of risks self-destructive risks
and that's why you need parents
especially fathers to kind of guide
between some guide a path between those
two extremes
and now for once again my favorite part
of the day reading the ads i'm so
excited about these ads yes
yes we get to read more ads all right if
you've been searching for a daily
morning podcast without an agenda look
no further than the morning wire which
has been topping the apple and spotify
charts since its recent release it's the
only daily news podcast that values your
time and the truth
and while we're working overtime to
bring you the news you need to know we
need your help to keep the facts
trending towards the number one spot so
subscribe and start listening now to
morning wire on apple spotify or
wherever you listen to podcast and leave
a five-star review
if you're as excited as i am and finally
also if you've been wondering what it's
like to sit front row at candace's new
show candace then you might just be in
luck
if you sign up now as a daily wire
member with code vip you'll get 25 off
your new membership and be automatically
entered for a chance to win a trip for
two you and a guest at the daily wire
studios to see candace live not only
will you meet candace you'll get an
inside look at her studio in front row
seats to watch her take down leftist
live and in action on her talk show this
is something that will make your life
worth living your life is miserable
unless you can do this this will make it
all worth it so get a great deal on the
new dailywire membership at
dailywire.com subscribe with code vip
and 25 off so you can automatically be
entered for a chance to win the vip
experience
so exciting now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
you know if you listen to the show on
friday you would have heard a brief
segment about halfway in where we
discussed a recent census report which
shows that the white population in this
country has declined for the first time
in american history whites have dipped
below
60 of the overall population another
first
and among young americans racial
minorities are now the majority
um now i say we discussed the report but
really we discussed more so the reaction
to the report which was positively
rapturous on the left the most blatant
example was jennifer rubin with the
washington post who exclaimed that the
diminishing number of whites is
fabulous news
and elsewhere the celebration was
couched in more sanitized language but
was nonetheless apparent so take this
article
from a guy named peniel joseph with cnn
who scolded the white people who are
worried about the census data labeling
them all white supremacists to include
tucker carlson of course and joseph then
wrote and yet america's changing
demographics tell a different more
inspiring story rather than a narrative
of white decline what if we saw in this
data the increasing numbers of racially
blended families and mixed-race children
and understood and understood them as
signs of a more racially diverse
economically just and culturally rich
future
now it is he says inspiring for there to
be fewer white people around it is more
just and more culturally rich he says
which is obviously to say that a whiter
country would be culturally impoverished
and less just
this is how the left has generally
framed it to be a less white country by
their telling
is to be a manifestly better country
that's why they celebrate the decline of
the white population it's why they
actively seek to
facilitate that decline in terms of
percentages by inviting unchecked
immigration across the southern border
um it's why they're very concerned about
making sure that white people have less
institutional power
and are really clear about that that's
that's what they want to do they put
policies like affirmative action into
place to achieve that end
now i said on friday that although this
is all obviously true
and they don't make any attempt to hide
it even so you're not allowed to point
out that any of this is happening
if you do you'll be accused of engaging
in the allegedly white supremacist
replacement theory
i also predicted during that segment
that media matters would post that same
segment and accuse me of advancing white
supremacist conspiracy theories well
like a prophet of old i had correctly
predicted the future once again so later
that day after that segment aired media
matters published this they say on
youtube daily wire host embraces white
nationalist conspiracy theory
now our friends and media matters are
nothing if not predictable but it wasn't
just them a woman named robin panacia
over at the wonkette blog posted an
article titled matt walsh scared we are
secretly trying to replace him and all
other white people
then she goes on
many years ago when we were all so much
more innocent the only people who
believed in the great replacement theory
were neo-nazis and when you tell normal
people about this even normal people who
were themselves kind of racist they
would be pretty surprised that it was
that it was a thing mostly because of
how it sounds ridiculous and also is in
fact ridiculous
but matt walsh doesn't think that only
rabid white supremacists should be able
to indulge themselves in absurd racist
fantasies in which they are the truest
victims he wants tactful suit-wearing
white supremacists to have that
opportunity as well why limit oneself
really now take a quick step to the side
here to say that
um
i'm not worried about this lady or media
matters calling me a white supremacist
that term has no meaning
i'm sure robin would call the barista at
starbucks a white supremacist if he
misspelled her name on her cup which by
the way they probably do all the time
incidentally because her parents
injected an unnecessary why into her
name a move that doomed her to a life of
writing whiny poorly constructed blog
posts like this one
the point is that these people find
white supremacy around every corner and
in every crack and crevice of the earth
to them i'm a white supremacist because
i exist and i'm white and i lapse
sometimes into the nasty habit of
expressing my own opinions rather than
their opinions
so the label could not be more
irrelevant to me with that said
i do take exception to the claim that i
am tactful and wear suits
those latter accusations are entirely
without basis i assure you
in any case reading a bit more here um
after extensively quoting me robin
writes quote
whenever anyone says you can't talk
about this they rarely mean that no one
can talk about it they just mean that if
they talk about it in the way they're
talking about it people will think
they're super racist which is a very
fair conclusion to reach almost any time
matt walsh's mouth is open and he's not
just saying things about women
we're letting people into america to
escape bad conditions in their home
countries
it's not for the purpose of replacing
white people no white people are being
murdered in the process of immigration
happening
well that's kind of news to me
as far as universities and positions of
power go no these can't all be for white
people that's not white genocide that's
just sharing white people are not
entitled to have all of the positions of
power it's not replacement it is making
things more fair
if one does think that white people do
have that intrinsic right then they are
in fact white supremacist
oppressors have always seen those they
sought to oppress as a threat this is
nothing new the best way to preserve an
unjust hierarchy is by convincing those
at the top in the middle that if those
on the bottom get any power they'll turn
around and do some oppressing themselves
if only as an act of revenge
now so it's a review
in case you're lost at this point
it is a racist conspiracy theory to say
that white people are being replaced
that's not happening at all
it's completely false how dare you
at the same time there is a racial
hierarchy in this country and white
people are at the top of it and are by
their nature oppressive and it's
therefore important to well replace them
with non-white people
indeed the people complaining about
being replaced are racist for not
wanting to be replaced and also for
claiming that they are being replaced
because they're totally aren't being
replaced even though they are and it's
good and they should like it but it's
not happening
make sense
no well of course not because the
incoherence is entirely by design
now back in realityville there is there
is no racial hierarchy that's not what
this is about the hierarchy exists in
the imagination of women with
unnecessary wise in their names the
point the real point is simply that
at least partly as a as a result of
deliberate policy choices and the
actions of our most powerful cultural
institutions
the overall percentage of white people
in the country and of white people
admitted into universities and placed in
positions of power and so on
is being reduced
and non-white people are being placed
into those vacated areas
i think you could really call that
replacement but if you don't like
replacement that's fine let's put that
put that to the side how about a
different r word how about reduction
can i call it white reduction
nobody can deny that there's a
significant amount of white reduction
taking place both in the population and
especially institutionally
now
so we're talking about white reduction
um
the question
is it good
to celebrate this
and to answer that question all we need
to do is imagine how it would sound for
someone to celebrate the reduction of
any other race of people
what if i was to react to news about a
reduction in the black population by
describing it as fabulous
now you'll argue that it's different
because black people are in the minority
but why should that make it different
the point is that minority or majority
we should not treat any race as a
pestilence that needs to be cured
you know to treat any race as a problem
to be solved a plague to be contained
is unimaginably unspeakably racist
and if you're really getting hung up on
the minority aspect of this then fine
imagine that i were to celebrate
the reduction of the majority race in
any non-white foreign country so let's
take any non-white foreign country
where non-white people hold all of the
systemic power
and then imagine that i were to tell you
that this majority race is being
supplanted by a minority race and that
this is great news
now you would surmise
that i'm obviously racist against the
majority race you would ask me questions
like well
why are you celebrating that exactly i
mean what's wrong with that race being
the majority why have you decided that
it shouldn't be why is it a problem what
what are you so excited about what don't
you like about these people
and if i responded that the majority
race is naturally oppressive and
inherently bigoted
and that's why there needs to be less of
them
you would only become firmer in your
conclusion that i am nothing but a
ranting raving drooling bigot
and you would be right in that case
and that's the point
okay
white people are not entitled to
positions of power that's that's true
and nobody is saying they are
that's not the point
here's what i'm saying about white
people here's my here is my radical
statement and media matters here's the
part that i want you to clip
because you're basically my pr team at
this point i tell you to clip something
and post it and you do which is great so
here's the clip this one
um here's what i'm saying about white
people this is this is my extreme
extreme claim
white people
have the same moral worth as anyone else
and are therefore entitled to the same
respect
so any language that would sound
horrifically racist when applied to
other races is just as horrifically
racist when applied to whites
that's what i'm saying
i am the one advocating for equality
here
treating treating all races the same
with moral worth
and we don't talk about them like their
diseases to be reduced and contained
robin and media matters they're the ones
who want to treat white people as a
special case
if only for negative reasons
and that is why they are today certainly
cancelled
and we'll leave it there thanks for
watching thanks for listening have a
great day everybody godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens
production manager pablo vadowsky
the show is edited by sasha tulmachov
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
and makeup is done by niko geneva and
our production coordinator is mckenna
waters the matte wall show is a daily
wire production copyright dailywire
2021.
if you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle we'll tune in to the
ben shapiro show we'll get a whole lot
of that and much more see you there